♪ [vocalizing] ♪
Hey, I just got a text
from Charles, y'all.
He got on the wrong bus.
He's on the other side of town.
Other side of town?
But our concert is in an hour.
Yeah, I know,
but he wants us to warm up
and rehearse
Praise to the Lord.
Charles said that?
- In text.
- Okay, okay.
Well, if that's
what Charles said--
(woman)
Yeah, that's okay.
We got this.
- We can do this.
- [humming tone] We can do this.
We can do this.
Come on, y'all.
- [humming tone]
♪ Five, six, seven, eight ♪
(all)
♪ We lift up to the Lord ♪
♪ We give praise
up to the Lord ♪
♪ We sing merrily
♪ Give thanks up to the Lord ♪
♪ We lift up to the Lord ♪
♪ We give praise
up to the Lord ♪
♪ We sing merrily
♪ Give thanks up to the Lord ♪
- ♪ I think you're
off of your note ♪
♪ You're going
higher than your note ♪
- ♪ Pretty sure
this is my note ♪
♪ In fact, I'm positive
- ♪ Because this is my note ♪
- ♪ Pretty sure
this is my note ♪
- ♪ Could have sworn
this was your note ♪
- ♪ That has never been
my note ♪
- ♪ Well, we can't have
the same note ♪
♪ So one of us is wrong ♪
- ♪ Why don't you worry
about your note? ♪
♪ I'll take care
of my own note ♪
- ♪ But it's a really,
really, really bad note ♪
- ♪ You are not Charles ♪
- ♪ I never said
that I was Charles ♪
- ♪ Well, you're acting
like you think you're Charles ♪
- ♪ Look, I know
that I'm not Charles ♪
- ♪ You can say that again ♪
- ♪ Well, you're both
off your notes ♪
♪ And it's messing
with the rest of our notes ♪
- ♪ Speak for yourself, Nyema,
I'm holding my note ♪
- ♪ I wasn't trying
to single you out ♪
- ♪ You said everyone
was off their notes ♪
(all)
♪ Not everything
is about you, Gina ♪
Huh.
♪ Kiss my black ass! ♪
(all)
♪ Oh, dear Lord ♪
♪ Where is ♪
♪ Charles? ♪
- This don't make no sense.
- Come on, man.
[all talking at once]
[haunting Western music]